I know there's a broad question being
asked what what do I think can be done
this year and while there are many many
choices I decided to talk about malaria
the reason I talk about malaria is that
there are a million children die every
year in Africa there we have all the
tools that are necessary to prevent
those decks in addition there is an
enormous economic toll to malaria and if
we can prevent these this disease and to
eliminate the mortality the child deaths
then we make a huge difference all it
takes is a united effort in countries by
people who have the wherewithal and the
capabilities to launch programs on a
very aggressive pudding the scale of the
war against malaria and such a coalition
has come together under roll back
malaria under a strong pass force that's
designed to create these from national
plans or health countries prepare
national plans to coordinate them into a
regional plan and go on an aggressive
timetable of implementation I believe
the time is right this year we should
have universal access to bed nets we
should have a universal access to the
next generation drugs so you have
universal access doing you're spraying
and if we are able to do that yeah
actually we can eliminate all malaria
deaths within the next three to five
mins that would be the one thing I would
take the work on this year hope you
agree love to hear your comments